no es habitual ver a la policía reprimir
con violencia manifestantes israelíeses
sobre todo en tel aviv los agentes
utilizaron gases lacrimógenos y bombas
de sonido para dispersar algunas de las
marchas contra la reforma judicial
impulsada por el gobierno de netaniacu
decenas de personas también fueron
arrestadas en este día llamado el día de
disrupción una jornada con múltiples
focos de protestas bloqueos de
carreteras interrupciones en la
circulación de trenes e incluso huelgas
temporales en lugares de trabajo y
centros educativos aún así el accionar
policial fue respaldado por el Primer
Ministro Benjamín taniagu quien acusó de
nuevo a los manifestantes y a la
oposición de fomentar la anarquía Y es
que estas protestas que se repiten cada
sábado se han extendido a convocatorias
en días laborales y hoy en particular
coinciden con otra jornada en la que la
coalición gobernante avanza sus
proyectos de ley en el parlamento para
según sus detractores debilitar al poder
judicial una de las propuestas que más
ha irritado los manifestantes es la que
evita que el fiscal general o la Corte
Suprema puedan iniciar un proceso para
apartar al Primer Ministro este proyecto
ha recibido una aprobación preliminar y
si se convierte en ley brindaría a
netaña justo cuando este febrero el
supremo aceptó una petición para evaluar
si el Primer Ministro es apto para el
cargo ya que está impulsando una amplia
reforma judicial mientras él mismo se
enfrenta a un juicio por varias causas
de corrupción otro controvertido
proyecto que hoy obtuvo una aprobación
preliminar fue el de la pena de muerte
para condenados por terrorismo una ley
que se aplicaría solo atacantes
palestinos lo que ha llevado a
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos a
calificarla de ra